(27 de febrero de 2019, Michael Cohen, el
abogado y hombre de confianza de Donald Trump
durante la última década comparecía ante
el Congreso de los Estados Unidos. Su declaración
fue toda una bomba contra el presidente.
Cohen le acusó de complicidad con Rusia durante
la campaña electoral así como de varios
delitos fiscales. Además describió a Donald
Trump como un racista, un estafador y un tramposo.
Con esta declaración Michael Cohen añadía
más leña a un fuego que cada día parece
más vivo y que está a la espera del informe
final del fiscal especial Robert Mueller,
cuyas conclusiones podrían desembocar en
la apertura de un proceso de impeachment en
la Cámara de Representantes.)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, mientras
Michael Cohen despotricaba sobre Donald Trump,
el presidente de los Estados Unidos se encontraba
a miles de kilómetros de Washington, en pleno
viaje a Hanoi, la capital vietnamita, para
reunirse con el líder de Corea del Norte,
Kim Jong Un, en la que ha sido la segunda
cumbre entre ambos mandatarios.
Una cumbre que ha sido tachada por la mayoría
de los medios de comunicación como un fracaso.
Y las preguntas que tenemos que hacernos son,
¿ha sido realmente la cumbre de Hanoi un
fracaso? ¿En qué punto se encuentran las
negociaciones entre los Estados Unidos y Corea
del Norte? Atentos.
Vale, hay excepciones pero en general las
segundas partes de una película no suelen
ser tan emocionantes como la primera. ¿No
os parece?
Pues algo así es lo que ha ocurrido en Hanoi.
Apenas ocho meses después del histórico
encuentro en Singapur, Donald Trump y Kim
Jong Un se han vuelto a ver las caras.
Las expectativas apuntaban a que en esta ocasión
se llegaría a un acuerdo concreto, con plazos,
metas, objetivos.
(Sin embargo, la cumbre terminó de forma
precipitada sin que se llegara a ningún entendimiento.
Por un lado, Corea del Norte exigió que se
eliminaran todas las sanciones internacionales
a cambio de desmantelar su principal complejo
nuclear - Qué no el único -, el complejo
de Yongbyon, un centro dedicado a la producción
de plutonio y combustible de uranio para las
armas nucleares norcoreanas.
Por otro lado, Estados Unidos exigía que
fuera Corea del Norte quien diera el primer
paso, desmantelando todo los centros de producción
y desarrollo de su programa nuclear, incluidos
los centros clandestinos… para más tarde
contemplar el alivio de las sanciones internacionales.)
Cómo veis las posiciones no eran del todo
compatibles: en la agenda norcoreana no estaba
renunciar a su programa nuclear y Estados
Unidos no estaba dispuesto a hacer concesiones
a cambio de prácticamente nada.
"El dilema al que nos enfrentamos es que los
norcoreanos en este punto no están dispuestos
a congelar completamente sus programas de
armas de destrucción masiva. Por lo tanto,
otorgar muchos, muchísimos miles de millones
de dólares con el alivio de sanciones, nos
pondría en la posición de subvencionar el
desarrollo continuo de armas de destrucción
masiva en Corea del Norte ". Un funcionario
del departamento de estado al Washington Post)
Pero, amigos, no os penseis que todo esto
fue una sorpresa.
Es verdad que Donald Trump se las prometía
muy felices pensando que a cambio de garantizar
un futuro esplendoroso para Corea del Norte,
inversiones y desarrollo económico, iba a
conseguir convencer a Kim Jong Un. Fijaos.
Nuestro equipo de los Estados Unidos llegó
a Corea del Norte para organizar la cumbre
entre Kim Jong Un y yo. Realmente creo que
Corea del Norte tiene un potencial brillante
y que será un gran país económico y financiero
algún día. Kim Jong Un está de acuerdo
conmigo en esto. ¡Pasará!
Pero… lo cierto es que su equipo era mucho
menos optimista.
Tanto el secretario de estado Mike Pompeo
como el consejero de seguridad nacional, John
Bolton habían dejado caer sus dudas acerca
de que se pudiera llegar a un acuerdo.
El caso es que esto es lo que se ha contado
en todos los medios y el motivo por el que
la cumbre se ha considerado un auténtico
fracaso.
Pero... esperad un momento, ¿realmente fue
la cumbre un fracaso?
Pues, sí….y no.
Queridos amigos, no nos vamos a engañar,
en VisualPolitik no somos precisamente, lo
que viene a ser, lo que se dice, simpatizantes
de Donald Trump… pero también siempre tratamos
de ser objetivos [lo que no quiere decir neutrales]
Pues bien, el caso es que creemos que podemos
plantear 3 motivos por los que la cumbre a
diferencia de lo que han dicho en casi todos
los medios de comunicación no fue en absoluto
un fracaso.
Atentos.
(OBJETIVO: VIETNAM)
Con más de 90 millones de habitantes, aunque
puede pasar desapercibido, Vietnam se ha convertido
no solo en uno de las economías de más rápido
crecimiento en el mundo durante las últimas
tres décadas, sino también y cada vez más,
en toda una prioridad para los Estados Unidos.
Sí, puede resultar sorprendente, pero estos
dos países, protagonistas hace menos de medio
siglo de una de las guerras más largas y
duras que se recuerdan son hoy dos importantes
socios económicos y políticos.
[Por cierto, ¿queréis una prueba de
estas buenas relaciones?: en marzo del año
2018, el portaaviones USS Carl Vinson recaló
durante cuatro días en Da Nang. Fue la primera
visita a Vietnam de un buque militar de los
Estados Unidos desde que terminara la guerra
en 1975.]
El caso amigos, es que la visita de Donald
Trump no tenía solo un objetivo, sino dos.
Fijaos.
(La Casa Blanca aprovechó este viaje para
estrechar lazos con el gobierno vietnamita.
Trump se reunió tanto con el presidente como
con el primer ministro y presidió un acto
simbólico en el que varias compañías aéreas
vietnamitas encargaron más de 20.000 millones
de dólares en la compra de aviones y servicios
a compañía estadounidenses.
[Especialmente a Boing, claro.]
Sobre la mesa, además, está la negociación
de un acuerdo de libre comercio y la venta
de miles y miles de millones de dólares en
equipamiento militar.)
Y es que amigos, Estados Unidos quiere convertir
a Vietnam en uno de sus socios más importantes
en esta zona del mundo, tanto a nivel político
como económico.
¿Por qué? Pues porque Vietnam se está desarrollando
a pasos agigantados, es un país muy abierto
al comercio, tienes unas relaciones poco amistosas
con China y su mano de obra tiene unos costes
laborales muy reducidos.
En otras palabras, es un país perfecto para
inundarlo de dólares.
Aunque, no tengo claro cómo va a sobrellevar
Trump el hecho de que Estados Unidos tenga
un déficit comercial con Vietnam de casi
40 mil millones de dólares.
[¿Son los vietnamitas también unos ladrones?]
Por su parte Vietnam aspira a recibir todos
esos dólares que pueden acelerar su desarrollo,
su autonomía de China y su posición de liderazgo
en todo el sudeste asiático.
(Hanoi está desesperado por una mejor relación
con Washington y le gustaría un acuerdo de
libre comercio con la administración Trump
para garantizar que no sea totalmente dependiente
de los mercados y consumidores chinos. [... ] Vietnam
también desearía comprar grandes cantidades
de EE. UU. Avanzadas equipo militar. Harry
J. Kazianis. director de Estudios Coreanos
en el Centro para el Interés Nacional.
Pues bien, qué mejor que darle a Vietnam
el protagonismo y la influencia política
de albergar una cumbre de este tipo. Y si
además lo aprovechas para estrechar lazos
pues… mejor que mejor, ¿no os parece?
Pues eso es precisamente lo que ha ocurrido.
(LAS CARTAS SOBRE LA MESA)
Os lo contamos aquí, en VisualPolitik, en
un pasado vídeo sobre la cumbre en Singapur.
El concepto que Corea del Norte tiene sobre
lo que significa “desnuclearizar” la península
coreana es muy diferente al que se tiene en
el resto del mundo.
Corea del Norte no tiene ninguna intención
de renunciar a sus armas nucleares, no al
menos de una forma tan fácil.
Veréis, seguro que no sorprendo a nadie si
digo que el régimen norcoreano es una dictadura
cruel con un historial de respeto a los derechos
humanos absolutamente lamentable.
(Aislado del resto del mundo y dirigido con
mano de hierro durante 3 generaciones por
la familia del actual líder, Kim Jong Un,
hablamos de un país donde sus habitantes
pueden ser enviados a prisión simplemente
por ver, leer o escuchar medios de comunicación
internacionales.
Un país donde cualquier disidencia o discrepancia
respecto al gobierno te puede conducir a brutales
campos de reeducación y trabajos forzados.
Un país con un estado que explota a su propio
pueblo enviándoles a trabajar por el mundo
en condiciones de semiesclavitud.)
Pues bien, a pesar de todo ello, las ansias
de Donald Trump por conseguir su preciado
acuerdo y su predilección por los dictadores
y políticos autoritarios blanqueó en cierto
modo las políticas de Pyongyang.
("Todos están cuidando sus propios intereses.
Nadie está mirando por los intereses de los
ciudadanos de Corea del Norte". Brad Adams,
director para Asia de Human Rights Watch)
[De hecho, os aseguro que a nivel personal
una de las cosas que más deleznables me han
resultado ha sido ver al Presidente de los
Estados Unidos regando la oreja del tirano
norcoreano. ¿Os imagináis que hiciera lo
mismo con Nicolás Maduro?]
Pues bien, ahora gracias a esta “fallida”
cumbre las cartas han quedado sobre la mesa:
el régimen de Kim Jong-Un no tienen ninguna
intención de renunciar ni a su poder ni a
sus armas nucleares.
Y que esto quede claro, además de ser un
tributo a la verdad le da fuerza a los Estados
Unidos de cara a las siguientes negociaciones.
Por así decirlo ha bajado las expectativas
en casas - algo que hacía falta.
Y además le ha dado fuerza a Washington en las negociaciones, que por supuesto van a continuar.
Corea de Norte necesita superar las sanciones.
Y, amigos, aún nos queda el tercer punto.
(LAS REFORMAS, TODO DEPENDE DE LAS REFORMAS)
Amigos, hace apenas 30 años, Vietnam estaba
en una situación incluso peor que la de Corea
del Norte. El país estaba destrozado por
las guerras, sufría el bloqueo de China,
Estados Unidos, Europa e, incluso, de sus
vecinos del sudeste asiático. Su economía
estaba literalmente hundida, cerca del 70%
de sus habitantes vivían en condiciones de
extrema pobreza.
Desde entonces las cosas han cambiado bastante.
Hoy poco más del 3% de la población de Vietnam
vive en condiciones de extrema, extrema pobreza.
Del 70 al 3%]
Pues bien, el caso es que Vietnam puso en
marcha de forma unilateral su plan de reformas,
conocido como el Doi Moi, antes, incluso,
de reconciliarse con la comunidad internacional.
Es decir, mientras continuaba sufriendo el
bloqueo económico de Estados Unidos.
¿Qué mejor ejemplo para Corea del Norte?¿Qué
mejor acción que involucrar a Vietnam en
este proceso y ponerlo como ejemplo? Qué
en Pyongyang sepan mejor lo que podrían llegar
a conseguir.
("El éxito de la economía vietnamita se
debe a su decisión de normalizar las relaciones
con los Estados Unidos en 1995 [...] Le diría
a nuestros amigos norcoreanos que siempre
que tengan un conflicto con los Estados Unidos,
no podrán desarrollar su economía de manera
adecuada ".
Os lo hemos contado en varios vídeos que
os dejamos en la descripción - Kim Jong-Un
parece estar decidido a impulsar la reforma
económica y la apertura de Corea del Norte.
Pues bien, qué mejor que meter presión mostrándole
en primera persona el resultado.
Amigos, Estados Unidos parece tener claro
que el problema norcoreano sólo se resolverá
con una nueva estrategia más enfocada en
el comercio que en las armas. Puede que la
cumbre no diera el resultado esperado pero
¿fue un fracaso?
Ya veis que tal vez la respuesta no sea tan
claro como parece a simple vista, sobre todo
si tenemos en cuenta la nueva estrategia de
la Casa Blanca.
(No vamos a invadir a Corea del Norte. No
estamos tratando de derrocar al régimen de
Corea del Norte. Estamos listos para un futuro
diferente. Es más grande que la desnuclearización
... Estoy absolutamente convencido, y lo que
es más importante, el Presidente de los Estados
Unidos está convencido de que es hora de
pasar los 70 años de guerra y hostilidad
en la península de Corea. No hay razón para
que este conflicto persista por más tiempo.)
Por cierto, ¿Apoyas la estrategia de la Administración
Trump hacia Corea del Norte? Dejame tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si os ha resultado interesante este vídeo
no olvideis darle a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.